okay my first pick there's gonna be an
easy one so Joe Montana obviously is not
in this draft because we eat is the Joe
Montana Memorial Drive even though you
said you did it yes I did it I did it
but that was such a basic answer that
everyone's expecting that let's do
something big didn't he didn't look
weird in the uniform that's the problem
it said I'm fine that he's off the board
I don't know so I don't think I
necessarily would have taken him that's
limit Area Memorial Draft even though
he's not dead
go ahead let's live Mike let's throw
caution to the wind let's be young kids
again okay here it is Emmitt Smith
Arizona Cardinals every time I see this
it looks fake I cannot believe he played
for the Arizona Cardinals it was so
weird
even at the time look at that it was
weird when it happened it was weird you
know every time he he got a carry for
the Cardinals Emmitt Smith is a cowboy
he's one of the most iconic Cowboys and
then he went and obviously it was a
detail out of his career he got who did
he break the record with the with the
Cardinals yes he did
yeah so that's even weirder when he has
like a historic monumental moment and
it's Emmitt Smith in a Cardinals uniform
crazy to see he is number one on my list
second Emmitt Smith reference today we
made the reference earlier to your beard
is weird your stache is trash and his
new uniform with the Cardinals was weird
but he did set the all-time rushing
record while a member of the Arizona
Cardinals first picked for me and we've
talked about this recently and I
actually found the image of the football
card because what they did they did a
Photoshop of the quality of the Tom
Brady photo shops that we had during the
TV segment a moment ago John Unitas to
the chargers that is weird
still weird all these years later well
before your time big cap but an iconic
member of the Baltimore Colts finishes
out his career with the Chargers and
they basically took a picture of him in
a Colts uniform and got like a yellow
felt pen and turned some of the white
yellow to make it look like a Chargers
uniform that was the football card for
Johnny Unitas with the then San Diego
Chargers after he left the Baltimore
Colts and that still resonates for me
all these years later because that's
it's one of those things that like as
you're a young football fan it's one of
those things it's just like
your bubble that like wait a minute it's
not like college where you only ever
play for one team like you can play like
a guy who's a star can play for another
team so that one's weird and I'll never
forget that when John unites us on the
Chargers great pic Mike you just locked
up our 80 and older audience stop just
stop you all right I'll go with another
one that's a no-brainer for me this one
makes no sense when you look at it and
it's a guy who actually was on four
different teams Mike one of them he
never actually played for suited up for
its Jerry Rice on his third team the
Seattle Seahawks so obviously he went
49ers to Raiders which Bay Area both
classic jerseys it doesn't look as weird
but when you see a picture of Jerry Rice
on the Seahawks that is jarring to see
it makes no sense for your brain of
course he finished with the Broncos but
he never actually you know suited up in
a game so Jerry Rice with the Seahawks
is my next pick do we have a picture
because it looks weird it really does
when you see it it looks very very weird
and I recall it correctly and look it
was even even weirder when I went to the
Broncos because he never really did
anything with the Broncos I mean he's a
guy who didn't have just one team after
the team he was excellent with he had
the Raiders he had the Seahawks who at
the time were in the same within the
same division then No 2002 is when the
Seahawks left the AFC West was like the
AFC West or after he left the 49ers with
the Seahawks and then the Broncos
alright that's a good one
you know see for me the weirdest ones
were when I was a kid so you're gonna
laugh at this one no Franco Harris
Seattle Seahawks far weirder than Jerry
Rice Seattle Seahawks because first of
all the Seahawks were a fairly new team
so everything about the Seahawks was
weird
in the late 70s on top of that one of
the most iconic players in the history
of football the Immaculate reception
recently named the number one play of
all time in 100 seasons a professional
football and for me growing up 60 miles
from Pittsburgh coming Franco Harris was
just a larger-than-life figure I see him
now and I'm still in awe it seems like
every year on the way back from the
Super Bowl were on the same plane the
guy's great I can't a mad
with a team other than the Steelers and
that image of him sitting on the bench
with the Seattle Seahawks is just
jarring to me still all these years
later so I know I know where I'm gonna
do well with the over 60 crowd but
Franco Harris to the Seahawks far
weirder than Jerry Rice to the Seahawks
that's a good pic that's a good pic it's
not a great pic because I have a great
third pic and I think we actually
probably should go four rounds in this
draft because we probably have a little
bit of time but my third pick and I have
many more than I could handle
thanks and producer yeah my third pick
is going to be one that I think most
people forget even happened Randy Moss
who was on a bunch of different teams on
the Tennessee Titans that one makes no
sense and when you see it you can see
Randy Moss we close your eyes you can
see Randy Moss on the Patriots you could
see him on the Vikings obviously he's a
Viking and you could also see him kind
of on the Raiders butt though but the
Titans look at that how weird does that
look that's I mean it's crazy to see a
guy like that who you can visualize even
on all the different teams he played but
you can never visualize him being on the
Titans in there he is
2010 what happened was he was in the
last year of his contract with the
Patriots and he was complaining about
his future with the team they traded
into the Vikings for a third-round pick
and it was Nirvana for Vikings fans
Randy Moss is back he had at the press
conference
get your 84 jerseys out and and I was at
the game at MetLife Stadium where he
caught the touchdown pass it was Brett
Favre's what was at 500 or something
like that and then all of a sudden he
was cut Brad Childress cut him in part
because there was a Friday during the
season where he criticized the catering
that was done that day he said he
wouldn't feed that bleep to his dogs he
was cut the following Monday Brad
Childress called him a programmatic non
fit whatever that means there's an SAT
board for you big cat and your buddy
Jeff Fisher claimed him on waivers with
the Titans he finished the year eight
games four starts six catches for 80
yards sat out 2011 came back the
following year for the 49ers
there's your Randy Moss history lesson
it's great lesson and and I think what
comes down to like all these jerseys
that we're throwing out there is if you
go to a historic franchise
and you're a hall-of-famer like Randy
Moss when he goes to the 49ers when he
goes to the Raiders it doesn't look as
jarring because those are historic
franchises that feel like their home of
Hall of Famers it's when you have a
Randy Moss on the Titans or you have a
Jerry Rice on the Seahawks before they
obviously had their success with Russell
Wilson that's where it's like what's
going on here and Tom Brady if he goes
to the Bucks or the Titans or the
Jaguars like there's a few teams out
there that it would look very very weird
if he put their uniforms on and and that
makes me even more convinced if he does
leave and and look Vegas has it at 1 to
2 that he's gonna stay with the pages if
he does leave to me I think it's the
49ers of the Patriots and I don't know
that the 49ers are even interested in
Tom Brady I think he would be interested
in them it's the team he grew up rooting
for and I think of all the other
uniforms big head he would look the most
natural and normal in the 49ers uniform
bite without question every other
uniform would not look right
maybe the Raiders medve it would be cool
to see him in the Raiders uniform and
that that I think maybe I would buy a
Raiders Brady Brady Jersey that would be
the hottest selling jersey of all time
without question but I think the 49ers
makes the most sense
okay what about a visual standpoint last
pick for me I thought we were doing i
producer I thought we were doing four
rounds my next pick my next pick is John
Unitas LA Rams back in the 70s again you
can give me a hard time but these are
the I'm not Johnny Unitas Joe Namath
with the Rams back in the 70s sorry Joe
Namath with the Rams back in the 70s
after leaving the Jets that was just
weird and I know the Rams weren't a bad
team then what's that for to drive
that's because I won the dry my picks
are so much better than yours and I won
the draft Mike because I win the draft
every single Friday I mopped the floor
with you I've said this a magical Friday
I'll say it again so my last pick
because everyone knows that I win here
does it happen
here's what's gonna happen I'm gonna get
15 emails saying why do you have that
guy on Friday he disrespects you he's a
big jerk he's insecure why does he have
to do that every week and I tell them
that that's okay he had a rough
week I I'm fine I'm gonna try to be a
good host you know I just let him and
I'll clean up the mess when he leaves
it's no problem
it's good to know that your wife has 15
email addresses my last pick my last
pick because I dominate this draft every
single time and we could never even
visualize Mike Florio and the word
success in the same sentence my last
pick is this Mike Florio there's also
applaud Mike Florio in the yellow jersey
tune in to the Tour de France this
summer
NBC Sports look at that you never could
see him in the lead you could never see
him be wearing that yellow jersey and
being number one isn't that weird we're
stretched into a fourth round just so
you could do that and you conspired with
the control room to create that stupid
image what am i wearing on my head I
don't know but I look good I look really
good I look like I'm actually gonna pass
you if we're being honest no even in
first place I look better than you all
right well now I can't do a real pic in
my for I thought let's just end it there
I was gonna pick Alan page with the
Bears because for me that hit home that
was painful to see the guy who in my
mind was the Vikings defense playing for
your Chicago Bears I couldn't watch it I
couldn't do it I refuse to accept it
that's a good one there it is yeah a
little bad let's throw out a couple just
rapid-fire Mike I had Edie read on the
Texans that is a crazy one i Brett Favre
obviously on the Vikings and Jay Cutler
on the Dolphins was personally shocking
for me but there are good ones out there
that you know it's crazy to see these
guys you're like wait what he's on that
LaDainian Tomlinson on the Jets still
kind of screws with me when I see that
even though he was paying decent this is
the only context in which I'll mention
this human being but OJ Simpson on the
49ers what bizarre after all those years
with the bills and and look you
mentioned Emmitt Smith to the Arizona
Cardinals and and I think it got less
weird for this guy I'm gonna mention
because they had some success but man
the first time I saw Kurt Warner in that
Cardinals uniform I was like this this
isn't right this is not right he will
had the gloves on and he had the white
helmet with the mildly perturbed bird on
the side it's like this is this guy
is the greatest show on turf and you're
putting them in a Cardinals uniform but
they got to the Superbowl so that all
that was part of the fun of that ride
like it's I get legitimized the
franchise and it legitimize the concept
of Kurt Warner on the Cardinals
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports